[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker uh host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast he can be found on
social media at Ross Tucker NFL he was
working last night Dolphins and the
Patriots and he joins his courtesy of
DraftKings good morning good morning
Ross how are you buddy morning Dan I'm
doing fantastic how about yourself well
uh great you know it's a foot Monday
overreaction what is the overreaction
today that you would caution people
against well I I think probably going
too far down the road with some of the 0
and2 teams I do think there are some
concerns with the Cincinnati Bengals or
even the Chargers because it feels like
the Chargers are the same team just a
different year but I think especially
now with a 17 game slate I think it's a
little bit too early
to start to throw out all those stats
and all those numbers and make it seem
like those teams are done um I know
people still think they have a chance to
make the playoffs and all that but 0
and2 doesn't feel as punitive as it used
to all right let me run down the 0 and2
teams right
now you tell me these this this team
will make the playoffs
Bears
Bengals
Broncos Cardinals
Chargers
Patriots
Texans
Vikings is that it any of those gonna
make the
playoffs uh I I'll say the Bengals will
make the playoffs I'd be surprised if
they didn't the only other team I think
out of that group that has a chance is
the Chargers but it's it's unbelievable
Dan and I tweeted this yesterday I feel
like the Chargers every single game is
the same game is it ever not the
two-minute warning of the Chargers game
and whoever has the ball is down one
score and they're driving to try to win
the game and what's Curious to me Dan
about the Chargers is they don't win
their fair share of those so I don't
know how much of that's Brandon Staley
how much of that's Justin Herbert you
know we all love just Herbert we all
think he's a fantastic player we talk
about him as a top five quarterback but
these first two games he's had six
drives I think in the fourth quarter
where they could either have taken a
two-score lead to kind of put the game
away or when they were trailing he could
have led them to the game-winning score
and he hasn't been able to do it and I
think he's awesome and I probably would
blame Staley more for these close losses
than Herbert but still not a good look
right so you know it feels like when
you're in those situations and you watch
momes it feels like he always gets it
done Dan it feels like certain guys
either always get it done or have a high
likelihood of getting it done Herbert's
just not one of those guys for whatever
reason yeah but are you siding with the
coaches to blame more than the
quarterback or the other way around with
the
Chargers I'm gonna put more blame on
Brandon Staley yeah I mean I they've had
some Curious decision you know what's
fascinating to me about him Dan two
years ago okay all of the analytics
folks all of the young people they were
loving Brandon Staley because every
decision he made was based on you know
expected points added or win probability
he went straight by the numbers right
and I don't know if he got guny I don't
know if he lost his Stinger or his
confidence but I'm watching the game
against the Titans they're like at the
42 yard line fourth and one or something
and he punts it yeah I I'm always a
little and you could say maybe he
learned from prior mistakes but I'm
always a little bit skeptical of coaches
who it seems like have really changed
their philosophy like why did he change
and to me the most likely scenario there
is he was tired of getting criticized
for being different so if he's gonna go
down he'd rather be conservative and not
have people say well he he's too new age
he's too going with the analytics too
much yeah I know that we get caught up
in in this where these new coaches New
Philosophy then all of a sudden now it
feels like you have a coach who's
coaching for his job and now you get a
little more conservative there you know
Mike McDaniel he's a guy that's quirky
different you saw this last night with
his offense and that's a great offense
there but is he an analytics guy similar
to how Staley is and some of you know a
few other
coaches well he certainly understands
you know the mathematics of some of the
decision making that he underg goes
although you know I thought the 55 yard
field goal was a surprising decision by
him I mean I I would have thought that
he would go for it in that situation
late in the game the kick wasn't even
close which by the way Dan I am
convinced that Jason Sanders hooked that
ball to the left because the Patriots
had that kid schooler coming off the
edge again from the right the same way
he had blocked the first field goal with
the coolest field goal block technique
I've ever seen I think we're going to
see more teams do that not just to block
it but it's just distracting for the
kicker right it's like those guys are so
locked in and now you have a guy running
toward you from your peripheral vision
I'm convinced that that's part of the
reason why Sanders hooked it the way he
did well I think uh he surprised the
dolphins with that and then I think H
after that you know teams are going to
be aware of a guy who is moving and then
you just got to chip him uh but I'm
waiting for the NFL to go nope that's
that's illegal we're not going to allow
that anymore uh but it was it was a
great play by the Patriots to block the
kick we're talking to Ross Tucker
Westwood won CBS Sports NFL and college
football analyst joining us on behalf of
DraftKings well the Dolphins I think
we're waiting to see can the defense be
up to the task that the offense is with
the dolphins
how would you handicap what you saw with
the dolphins and how sustainable it is
yeah so I I think Dan they've been the
most impressive team in the AFC so far
this season I mean I know we all come
into the year and you talk about the
Chiefs and the Bengals and the bills but
for the Dolphins to do what they did two
and 0 on the road at pretty solid
football teams with the Chargers and the
Patriots and I think Dan it's the way
that they did it right so they threw the
ball all over the field
against the Chargers we all know that it
was awesome to go to New England now and
bich does a good job taking away Tyreek
Hill so the Dolphins run the ball as
much as they did with moster and then
play really good defense on the other
side of the ball I mean you're already
seeing the impact of Vic fangio they
didn't even have Jaylen Phillips who's
probably their best Edge rusher for that
game last night and they still held the
Patriots to only 17 points the Patriots
you know they really have their own
issues but I do think that was a highly
encouraging performance by the Dolphins
defensively they forced a couple
turnovers and right now I mean if you're
doing AFC Power Rankings I think it's
hard not to have the Dolphins number one
out of that group help me understand the
logic of the Jets against the Cowboys
with Zach Wilson as your quarterback and
yes you have a wonderful wide receiver
but you have two good running backs and
I thought the best way to neutralize
Dallas and Micah Parsons would be to run
the football football how do you explain
them running 11
times well I think part of that is they
didn't have early success but I don't
care I'm with you Dan I mean we've now
seen enough of Zach Wilson and we saw
him yesterday honestly the best thing he
does right now is run I mean he ran for
a bunch of yards ran for some first
downs which helped the Jets but that's I
think the biggest storyline today in my
mind Dan in the NFL is what are the Jets
going to really do a quarterback I mean
would you try to trade for somebody in
the next two weeks that let's say let's
say The Vikings lose at home Chargers
are in Minnesota like at what point do
you say all right what will you give us
for our starting quarterback here I mean
I know they have to come in and learn
the offense but are they going to stay
with Zach Wilson maybe get a backup uh a
veteran backup and they're going to go
into battle every week like like
this so I don't know that they're going
to give up the draft choices and the
money for a guy like Kurt Cousins of
that caliber to try to make a big swing
like that but they're going to bring
somebody else in and I would think that
they would bring somebody else in this
week because it might take that guy a
week or two to get ready right and you
don't want to wait too long I mean they
play the Patriots in the next game you
don't want to wait so long that you're
putting whoever you bring in I don't
know Case Keenum name your favorite
backup uh quarterback out there that
they could bring in who's just steady
Dan it just doesn't look to me like Zach
Wilson is comfortable that he believes
what he's seeing they need a guy in
there that can just make the layups and
not turn the football over they don't
need the highlight real stuff and I
think they wanted to give it a week with
Zach Wilson well now we saw it so I
think either today or tomorrow I think
the longer the Jets go before they give
themselves another option at quarterback
the more of a disservice they're really
doing to that entire
team that Dallas defense is real but
that's because you start with Micah
Parsons
um does he get the Lawrence Taylor
treatment now with offensive
coordinators here yeah I mean he already
is and he's still producing which is
incredible I mean he is is a phenomenal
phenomenal football player his change of
Direction uh his lateral agility his
closing speed I mean he's probably as
clo look we've had some unbelievable
guys Von Millers and dere you know
there's all kinds of guys but he is as
dominant of a guy as we've seen in a
long long time three games into or a
couple games into here his second year
in or third year in the NFL just
extremely impressive what I like about
what Dan Quinn does Dan he's moving them
around right and they're running stunts
if you just line them up in the same
place every time teams are going to help
that way every time so the fact that
they're moving him around and getting
him involved in stunts that allow him to
get freed up a little bit more is very
very smart he needs to be like a War's
Waldo guy so that the offense doesn't
know where he is so they can chip or
slide or whatever I know that there's
Wishful reporting with Colorado with
Dion I don't how good they are uh
Colorado State's not good Nebraska's not
good and they did beat TCU and they're a
three touchdown Underdog against Oregon
probably would be similar I guess
against USC uh the following week but uh
how much of this do you think is
sustainable this year with Dion in
Colorado I I think they're going to
struggle the next couple weeks um you
know I heard the poll question and I
think it's I think Alabama will do a
better job of fighting through their
struggles than Colorado will continue to
have success especially with Travis
Hunter being hurt and out for a couple
weeks you know I don't know that that
was a great TCU team that they beat it's
a terrific story Colorado has been
terrible forever they have a good team
but they really haven't beat a a top 20
caliber team there's a reason why
they're huge underdogs against Oregon I
would imagine they will be as well
against USC if they can hang with those
teams and win one of those games I would
be very very impressed he's done a
fantastic job but I don't think they're
at that level yet I mean that would be
unbelievable if they were at that I mean
you're talking about top 10 teams I
don't think Colorado is a top 10 team
yet good to talk to you as always Ross
where are you off to next weekend big
one Dan uh my first SEC on CBS game Old
Miss at Alabama Saturday 3:30 I can't
wait okay look at you look at
you uh hey great to talk to you safe
travels thank you so much that's Ross
Tucker joining us on behalf of uh
DraftKings and uh Westwood One CBS
sports analyst there